the british government has denied
allegations of hypocrisy after three
black english footballers were targeted
with online abuse
racist social media posts were directed
at marcus rashford
jaden sancho and bukayo sakam after
their missed penalties helped italy win
sunday's euro 2020 final
but players and campaigners have called
out the government for
fueling the abuse after comments about
players taking
a knee after the hate
came the love this mural of england
player marcus rashford now covered in
well wishes
after it was defaced following england's
euro 2020 final loss to italy
these are the true england fans one girl
leaving a note that read
keep up the good work marcus rashford
supports echoed by many here
these boys did really well for the team
this took us really far
so to get this kind of abuse like round
the corner from where i live it was just
shocking
rashford was one of three black england
players alongside jaden
sancho and bakayosaka abused online for
missing penalties in the finals shootout
for some of them to be abused is
unforgivable really
it's just not what we stand for and uk
prime minister boris johnson
also joined in the condemnation to those
who have been
directing racist abuse at some of the
players
i said shame on you and i hope you will
crawl back
under the rock from which you emerged
but the uk government happy to be
associated with the team's success
has faced calls of hypocrisy
england defender tyrone ming's had this
message for home secretary pretty patel
writing on twitter you don't get to
stoke the fire at the beginning of the
tournament by labeling our anti-racism
messages gesture politics
and then pretend to be disgusted when
the very thing we're campaigning against
happens that after patel had publicly
criticized players for taking a knee
i just don't support you know people
participating in
you know that type of gesture gesture
politics to a certain extent as well
do you think they have the right
outcomes did the england fans are right
taboo
well that's a choice for them quite
frankly
anti-racism campaigners say the
government must bear some responsibility
for how
fans behave people remember that
it's all debatable that you don't have
to take the knee because the prime
minister and the government
don't agree with it and so therefore you
know somehow
in their minds that also gives them some
kind of freedom to be abusive when it
comes to to black players in particular
in the meantime england's players will
continue to fight racism
both on and off the pitch
all right let's take the story now over
to the uk i'm joined by our
correspondent
charlotte chelsea pill she is in london
tonight good evening to you
charlotte this love affair between the
england football team
and the british government is it over
even before it started
i think the government might have wanted
to characterize it as a love affair i
mean the whole country was swept up by
this team and their success
in this tournament you did get members
of the government including the prime
minister posting pictures in england
shirts
supporting the team cheering them on
watching the games they really wanted to
show that they were
on board with this national moment this
national pride
in the success of the teams i'm not sure
necessarily though whether some of the
players would call this a love affair
whether that was a
they would consider it a mutual
attraction i think that that
is clear from some of the tweets that
you have uh
had from players uh in the aftermath of
the racist abuse suffered
uh by those three uh teammates you heard
one of those statements
in that report there and just to
reiterate tyrone ming's england player
uh writing directing a tweet at
the uk's interior minister the home
secretary here
saying you don't get to stoke the fire
at the beginning of the tournament by
labeling our anti-racism message is just
a politics
and then pretend to be disgusted by the
very thing we're
campaigning against extremely
strong words from an english football
player directed at the government and
one that's resonated
with a lot of people here even
conservative politicians now
are questioning uh how the uk government
should respond to this
a lot of them uh feeling very much that
the government has been put in a very
difficult embarrassing situation yeah
you can imagine a lot of people have
been rolling their eyes when they've
heard comments coming from
the prime minister what about the the
public response to these
racist um tweets on social media what
kind of backing are the players getting
well of course uh initially extremely
fierce
condemnations from uh all circles really
you had
uh prince william saying he was sickened
by this racist abuse
you had the football english football
association condemning this just
tweet after tweet condemning this racist
abuse what you've seen
now though is just a complete outpouring
of support for these players just look
at what happened
at the mural for one of those players
marcus rashford today
was defaced uh police are investigating
that since though it has been covered by
hundreds of messages of support
really moving images of children going
down their writing notes
showing their support their pride in
what the national team has achieved one
message in particular directed at marcus
rashford saying
thank you for all of our dinner that's
pointing to the fact that
this player marcus rashford not just
known for his
uh stance on racial injustice but also
social injustice as well
he's led a campaign to feed children
during school holidays one that the
nation really did get behind so huge
amount of
outpouring love for mark of love for
marcus rashford and these players
i've got 20 seconds charlotte we know
the team was booed at first when it took
a knee in protest against racism the
booing was silenced after the tournament
so where are we now back at square one
20 seconds
well i think that this instance incident
shows that racism is still
a problem and needs to be fought but i
think it will also give some
a good deal of hope looking at the
outpouring here
that the majority vast majority of this
country stands against racism like this
all right our very own charlotte chelsea
pill on the story for us in london
tonight as always charlotte thank you